[Music]
foreign
wait I should warn you before you step
inside the house
this is bad this is bad as much as I
need you
you can leave oh no yeah you should
leave if you want to leave it's fine
Gabby I'm not afraid if a couple goes
you say that now
but really this could change the course
of your entire life oh once you come
inside like that's it there is no no
going back I guess it's just a risk I'm
willing to take now about the money uh
you
perfect
all right damn yeah you did not have to
give me this much money I mean I don't
even know if I can take this no take it
I insist okay I'm taking it so won't you
tell me some more about this house huh
uh it's probably best I show you yeah
yeah let's do it okay
who are they
unclear I've asked around there are a
lot of colorful theories about this
place I uh okay well that's my son
we sleep in here for some reason it's
just safer here and it's just the two of
you
yeah well um father
oh hey pumpkin
um hey buddy do you want to come out and
and meet Mr Mathias
what's this you got one of the fence and
your line of defense do you have
action guy
who's who's action guy you know action
guy right the one with the shoe you
remember as a weapon yes uses the shoe
as a weapon and he would say in
punchline he said something he was um
say it again say it again boy you
remember that oh it's like Abuelita with
the chancla
maybe it was just
at my discount store what about you I
was a doctor in New York and my mother
was from here and we just wanted to make
her start I always wanted to come back
and
open a bed and breakfast wow that's an
unfortunate
involuntary reaction if you don't like
bed and breakfast they're fun it's just
honestly I look at it like a bunch of
strangers getting together talking to
each other pleasantries
really if I'm being honest totally my
worst nightmare
well that's helpful thank you
um we just you know don't have a lot of
family well I found this place on Zillow
I thought that this would be a great way
for my son to meet new and interesting
people he has trouble making
me oh me too and then things got really
bad terrible
yeah anyway father Kent mentioned that
you have this special camera lens
okay I think we'll start in this room oh
wait don't don't use the Flash
and what
they do not like that
maybe we start in the dining room with
the photos hmm
oh
chest
move these back
oh
it's in here now
y'all playing tricks I'll be uh you guys
think this is funnier
don't touch them
the photo photo right
from here for
uh
it's not doing it now but normally it
will turn its head and follow you it's
absolutely terrifying it is and you know
frazzled
[Music]
and the basement
sometimes I'll get like a sharp pain on
both of my sides and I walk this way so
okay
all right
hey if you want to just go back
downstairs and wait for us in your tent
that's okay okay honey no I want to do
this okay I got you Mommy's got you
a brave boy
[Music]
okay okay I'm here I'm here you're okay
you're okay
why don't you just Mosey on over if it's
so easy all you have to do hey look at
me there's one foot in front of you
[Music]
it's it's really only after midnight
right
barely not
[Music]
okay big boy
okay I'm just doing some final
calculations here good news
no ghosts
I know it can be scary big house like
this creeks in the night cold drafts
it happens but there's this thing called
The Power of suggestion yeah I probably
just need to calm down don't I
didn't hurt
[Music]
foreign
exist what exactly are they back on
Deadliest Catch the storm finally got
done blowing here
so we're gonna get started
on the bairdi grounds
get the rest of these pots on call it a
paradise season for 2018 and be done
don't you agree I do agree
two days after setting on the weapon for
the Believers Go sir is real is still
living and ghosts return to what they
hope is their final bairdi Hall let's go
Superstar
as we'll find out these orbs supposedly
the energy signatures of ghosts May
simply mean it's the average that'll get
us home
[Music]
foreign
hey there it's Ben right
oh no no
[Music]
okay let's try now without the Flash
Tower of suggestion
oh
[Music]